here ice laosi down to Suzuki sharp angle shot
barov had the post covered Lee will slide it ahead
doesn't get out Paul Coffield picks it off in deep
Coffield around the goal rid around try stuffed
onto the pan of ARL well Aria gets it back to the
point a s shot hit the goal post another shot in
es SK in front tense moments in the Islanders
crease but V off taks it out to that end though
they have kept the Islanders off the board in
the first period the better of the periods for
the Islanders plus 11 in the first they a minus 13
in third periods this season as Coffield comes up
with this par C from Suzuki he just shot it wide
will flip it out to Center in the back hand and D
gy will start it right back the other way turning
with it armia finds Gallagher a shot glove C made
in and out of the glove of varlamov and they pin
it to the boards in the corner Holstrom trying to
get a call it's dug free petta looking at front
ruling it Michael petta looks back to the point
shot towards the goal rebound came out just
flip wide by Stevens Islanders will bring it
back though here's Nelson Ro Nelson walking in
creating space it got in tight a one save by
Mono with 30 seconds left keeps it at no score
there's will jump in round the boards for Evans
back to the point pen gouie long shot from Baron
came out and vlov gotone back with the right p b
stacking up in front of varlamov trying to take
his eyes pu just not finding the back of the
net for Montreal then come again Gallagher
trying to fight off the chck ranov here's
arm well get the puck up the ice quickly Gallagher
wins a 50/50 Puck battle on the wall and really
soft on the wall are the Islanders and right
there ranov loses this battle to Gallagher
Paso's Puck fishing he doesn't get it so Aria
gets it and like saard who cut through the
middle on the ship before and couldn't get a
handle on it yeah that of an assist well you
don't want a little piece of tape in the wrong
place that just mess you up speaking of assist BR
Gallagher is 199 career assist on the armia goal
baren shot that one hit Anderson front sped fire
St you got to hope that if you just keep working
at it eventually something is going to happen and
he gets up in the high slot cuz he's wants to
be the third guy High the puck hits him in the
backside and when it hits him in the backside
it drops right down in front of him you see
Barron throws it and he follows the back and
what happens is as Riley doesn't adjust when
it hits him Riley's looking around but he
doesn't step up to take him gets it right
back from Monahan mat now Coffield back for
mat pass a little behind him for the onetime
Coffield has it now oh Cofield mat now he away
ends up along the boards in a race for it Monahan
look out Holm leaves the L short handed goals
he's got it now Simon Holm CAU from behind by
field pfield will bring it ahead Suzuki back
to the point zovi rebound and it looked like
Mahan might hit the back of caufield's
legs now mat again a shot glub save AR
Lov and he'll hang on dorak at the point Baron
holds the line goor walking in that shots the
by gager and that's stopped Baron long shot
that one through the body he just went wide
dorak back to Baron dorak Baron got him at the
onetime pulled it back now takes the shot TI by
Anderson just wide monad back to Anderson at
the point on timer Baron monad trying to take
it off the Eds marov being the safe here's
Anderson again on the loose Puck one hand
on it shuttles it towards the net [Applause]
[Music] [Applause] [Music] that gets Monahan
the puck they keep the puck alive Anderson
drives to the net palur doesn't pick him
up he protects the puck from Riley on his back
all he can do is shovel it to the net not much
on it but then stay on your feet big and strong
stay on top of the rebound slowski SC number 17
Jos St Lou let keep the pressure going it's
the top line out here's a chance Goldfield
[Applause] [Music] scores Sean McKenzie showed
all the zeros on the board let's getting those
zeros out of here good four check Suzuki does a
nice job on the one corner SLP Cy does a good job
in the opposite corner and Coffield who's sitting
out in front finds a sweet spot you see all the
iser players around him he circulates himself
till he finds the spot there slapy kicking out
the loose [Applause] Puck slashed away from him
by the Stick of mat good job of playing keep away
right now by the Islanders though 30 seconds left
in the penalty Anders Lee here's Nelson scores
well we mentioned how dangerous the Islanders are
short-handed not their seventh short-handed goal
of the Season mon just gets a bit laxed Nelson
walks right in he gets a step on Ma he's got good
reach he's a good skater he protects the puck and
then this one here I think he just drives it right
through him it looks like a go through him this
will give us a better angle at it yeah right right
through him and is STO and sent down the ice by
the isers that will do it just one shot on the man
Advantage for Montreal look out bar Mo that away
another chance for hor good solid penalty kill and
a good solid five on five shift after that to the
New York Islanders Nelson stretches to knock that
puck back to Dobson he'll skate it around the Zone
doson still withs it through and front they score
Nelson back door cuts the lead in half it's 4-2
in the minutes he plays and great effort there by
Nelson to dive and tip that puck to keep it alive
and then Noah doson gets up on his horse Takes the
puck circles the back of the net and the guy who
makes the effort and Dives to keep it alive he
gets rewarded and again it's mat that's on him
yeah Islanders came into this one backto back
games after playing Boston losing in a shootout
last night here's doson Threw It on goal rebound
came scor it's horback and the Islanders have
battled back to within one and right here they
just lose it clean it goes back to the blue line
and it's a shot to the net and you see Evans his
guy is Horvat but once the puck goes by him to the
net he starts to search for it and when he search
for for the pck he misses it and once you miss
it man oh man horvat's not good to miss it and
there it is in the back of the net and now with
554 to go a only a one goal lead as the New York
Islanders have scored three consecutive goals in
the third period he finds Paul Mar Far Blue Line
can't get into bar out B SL the by gie and coming
up the puck Suzuki finds the for takes a look at
[Music] [Applause] [Music]
the Islanders trying to get the puck in to the
corner gie lowers the boom on Palm and that
gives monell a chance to get to the pot instead
of Suzuki just trying to throw off the glass he
has the presence of mind be patient look in
the middle and the for is exactly where he's
supposed to 53 it sits as the time winds down
the Pu down in center and in the final home
game of 2023 the Montreal Canadians give their
fans a gift it's a 5-3 win over the Islanders